hello everyone welcome back this is the
seventh and final screencast in our
series on Advanced behavioral evaluation
for nlu in the previous screencast I
introduced the idea of having
adversarial train sets in the mix then I
did that in the context of adversarial
nli and I talked briefly about the
dynabench platform
for this screencast we're going to build
on those ideas this is going to be a
deep dive on the dynasent data set which
I was involved in creating you've
actually worked already with dynasent in
the context of assignment one and the
associated bake off I'm describing it
now because I think it introduces some
new Concepts and also because it might
be a useful resource for you as you
think about projects all our data code
and models are available on GitHub
dynasent is a substantial resource with
over a hundred and twenty thousand
sentences across two rounds and each one
of those examples has five gold labels
from crowd workers
there's the associated paper and as I
said round two for this was created on
dynabench with an interesting
adversarial Dynamic that I'll talk about
this is a complete project overview
we're going to walk through this diagram
in some detail at a high level though I
think you can see there are two rounds
and there are also two models in the mix
those are the red boxes and at each
round we're going to do extensive human
validation
let's dive into round one the starting
point for this is model zero which we
use as a device for finding interesting
cases naturally occurring on the web
those are human validated and that gives
us our round one data set
in a bit more detail model 0 is a
Roberta based model that was fine-tuned
on a whole lot of sentiment examples
these are the five benchmarks that we
use to develop this model all of these
data sets for us are cast as ternary
sentiment problems that is positive
negative and neutral and you can see
from this slide that we are training on
a really substantial number of sentiment
examples
we're going to Benchmark these models
against three external data sets sst3
Yelp and Amazon and the table here is
showing that the model does well on all
three of those benchmarks the results
are not Stellar I think this is a pretty
hard sort of multi-domain problem for
sentiment but in general this looks like
a solid device for finding interesting
cases and that's the role that this will
play we are primarily thinking of using
model 0 as a device for harvesting
examples from the wild
uh the space we explore is the Yelp open
data set and we use the following
heuristic we favor sentences where the
review is one star and model zero
predicted positive
and conversely where the review is five
star and model 0 predicted negative this
is a heuristic that we think on average
will lead us to examples that model zero
is getting incorrect
but it is just a heuristic the only
labels we use are ones that are derived
from a human validation phase this slide
is showing you the interface that we
used the code is actually available in
the project repository and you can see
at a high level that reviewers were
making a choice about whether a
sentiment had positive negative no
sentiment or mixed sentiment labels
each example was validated by five
workers
the resulting data set is quite
substantial this is a kind of summary of
the numbers first I would point out that
47 of the examples are adversarial which
seems to me a high rate but the data set
includes both adversarial and
non-adversarial cases I think that's
important to making a high quality
benchmark
there are two ways that you can think
about training on this resource the
standard one would be what we call
majority label training and this is the
case where you infer that the label for
an example is the label that was chosen
by at least three of the five people who
labeled it and if there is no such
majority label you put that in that
separate elsewhere category that leads
to a substantial resource
however we find that it is more powerful
to do what we call distributional
training in distributional training you
repeat each example five times with each
of the labels that it got from the crowd
workers and train on that entire set the
result is that you don't have to worry
about the no majority category anymore
so you keep all your examples and you
also intuitively get a much more nuanced
perspective on the sentiment judgments
that people offered some are clear cases
with five out of five and some actually
have pretty mixed distributions across
the labels and your training models on
all of that information then we find in
practice that that leads to more robust
models
for the Devon test we restrict attention
to positive negative and neutral to have
a clean three-class ternary sentiment
problem and we balanced across those
three labels for both Devon test
so how do we do well let's think first
about model zero and its performance on
this Benchmark this is a kind of summary
we set things up so that model 0
performs at chance on round one no
information coming from model zero about
the labels and then you have the summary
numbers here before from before on how
it does on all of those external
benchmarks
humans by contrast do extremely well on
round one we estimate that the kind of
F1 for humans is around 88 percent and
that's a high number and it also
arguably understates the level of
agreement so we note that 614 of our
1200 workers never disagreed with the
majority label so this looks to us like
a very high rate of agreement and
consistency for humans on this resource
and here just to round out the
discussion of round one are some
randomly sampled short examples showing
you every combination of model
prediction and distribution across the
labels focused on the majority label in
this case and you see a lot of
interesting nuanced linguistic things
and I think a lot of use of non-literal
language
let's move now to round two this is
substantially different We Begin from
model one and this is a Roberta model
that was fine-tuned on those external
sentiment benchmarks as well as all of
our round one data the intuition here
coming from the anali project is that we
should train models on previous rounds
of our own Dynamic data set collection
instead of harvesting examples from the
wild in this phase we're going to use
dynabench to crowdsource sentences that
fool model one will human validate those
and that will lead us to our round two
data set
let's think a little bit about model one
again this is a Roberta based classifier
and it is trained on those same external
benchmarks but now down sampled somewhat
so that we can give a lot of weight to
round one which is now in the mix
these models are still trained on a
substantial amount of data and we're
trying to do to offer some evidence that
round one is the important thing to
actually focus on for this model
how do we do this is a summary of
performance on the external data sets as
well as round one and you can see down
here that this model is getting around
80 percent on our round one data with
essentially no loss in performance on
those external benchmarks there is a bit
of a drop I think we are performing some
kind of domain shift by emphasizing
round one as I described but overall
we're maintaining pretty good
performance while doing quite well on
the round one data set
I want to do a deep dive a little bit on
how the examples were crowdsourced
because I think this is an interesting
Nuance around how to get people to write
productively in a crowdsourcing context
in the original interface we simply did
more or less what was done for anli
which we which is that we asked people
to write a sentence from scratch that
would fool the model in a particular way
we found though that that's a very
difficult creative writing task and it
leads people to do similar things over
multiple examples which we intuited
would lead to artifacts in the resulting
data set and so we switch to emphasizing
what we call the prompt condition in the
prompt condition we actually offer crowd
workers a naturally occurring sentence
that comes from the Yelp open data set
and their task is to edit that sentence
in order to achieve this task of fooling
the model
the result is a data set that's much
more high quality and has much more
naturalistic examples in it
for validation we did the same thing as
round one and that leads to a data set
that looks like this there are only 19
adversarial examples in this I think
this shows that by now in the process we
have a very strong sentiment model that
is very difficult to fool but 19 is
still a substantial number numerically
and so we feel like we're in good shape
overall it's a somewhat smaller
Benchmark but it has similar structure
we can do majority label training as
well as distributional training and we
have balanced Devon tests they just
happen to be a little smaller than round
one
how does model 1 do versus Humans well
again we set things up so that model one
would performed at chance on our round
two data and you saw that model 1 does
pretty well on the round one data for
humans though this round is extremely
intuitive our estimate of F1 for humans
is actually higher than for round one
we're now at around 90 percent
and here 116 of our 244 workers never
disagreed with the majority label again
a substantial level of agreement on what
are clearly very difficult sentiment
problems and just to round this out I
thought I'd show another sample of
examples from this round again showing
model 1 predictions and every way that
the majority label could have played out
and I think even more than in round one
what we start to see are examples that
make extensive use of intricate
syntactic structures and also intricate
use of non-literal language like
metaphor and sarcasm and irony as
techniques for coming up with examples
that are intuitive for us as humans but
are routinely very challenging for even
our best models
so that is dynasent let me use this
opportunity to just wrap things up with
a few conclusions these are all meant to
be open questions designed to have us
looking ahead to the future of
adversarial training and testing
core question here can adversarial
training improve systems I think overall
we're seeing evidence that the answer is
yes but there is some Nuance there and I
think it's going to take some
calibration to get this exactly right
what constitutes a fair non-iid
generalization test I introduced this
notion of fairness when we discussed the
analytic considerations around all these
behavioral evaluations and then this
became very pressing when we talked
about why some of the cogs and recog
splits are so difficult the question
arises whether it's even fair to be
asking our machine Learning Systems to
generalize in particular ways that might
nonetheless seem pretty intuitive for us
as humans
can hard behavioral testing provide us
with the insights we need when it comes
to certifying systems as trustworthy if
so which tests and if not what should we
do instead I think this is a crucial
question I think in a way we know that
the answer is no no amount of Behavioral
testing can offer us the kind of
guarantees that we're seeking but it is
it is a powerful component in getting
closer to deeply understanding what
these systems are like and certainly we
can use behavioral testing to find cases
where they definitely fall down but for
actual certification of safety and
trustworthiness I believe we will need
to go deeper and that is the topic of
the next unit of the course
fundamentally are our best systems
finding systematic Solutions if the
answer is yes we will feel as humans
that we can trust them and if the answer
is no even if they seem to behave well
in some scenarios we might always worry
that they're going to do things that are
totally baffling to us
and then finally the big juicy kind of
cognitive and philosophical question
where humans generalize in ways that are
unsupported by direct experience how
should AI respond in terms of system
design what should we do in order to
achieve these very unusual
quasi-cognitive quasi-behavioral
learning targets I don't have a way to
resolve this question but I think it's
really pressing when we think about
really challenging our systems to do
complex things with language